how many years have you been giving me
about a T-shirt oh my God every
time he interviews me he's got these
like really cool challenge fat t-shirts
I think it's been about
about 10 10 years 12 years I still don't
have one yeah we were just talking uh
before I came out here about how uh I
need I still owe him a t-shirt well
ladies and gentlemen
it's all ending tonight oh you got to
see yourself oh oh I'm sorry the
streak is over as I reach in my back
pockets
I want to show you I picked out a good
one let me see does anyone know Die Hard
everyone knows Die Hard oh I'm sorry but
let's take a look let's see what you got
ah There It Is Well man and it's
Christmas I like that you finally came
through huh and he thought I was joking
all these years I was damn serious about
the T-shirt man I I knew this was
coming and I just want to point out
nakatomi Plaza Christmas party it
doesn't say die hard but it's die hard I
appreciate it you know what I mean we
can put it on the side or something but
yeah but it's over don't let me forget
it though right I will not I'm sorry for
uh making that happen but this is years
in the making
um so first of all I want to give a huge
thank you to IMAX and Sony for
partnering up to do the screening and
obviously a thank you to you for for
doing this tonight so I'm curious uh if
someone has never seen anything you've
directed what is the first thing you'd
like them watching and why well training
day probably Training Day
good question uh training day was really
you know
it was the film that uh this that was
most personal uh at that time in my life
uh it was a film that I was I was
looking for a movie like that I was
writing uh
a story about a cat named monster Cody
based on the book called Monster
um but I couldn't get that film made it
was about the streets at uh L.A he
was he started killing when he was 11
years old you know it's an amazing story
I would have completely it up
though if I'd have got it made because I
was focused on the wrong hero his mother
was the hero of the story right so back
then I didn't realize that
um but I couldn't get that movie made
and luckily I didn't but when Training
Day came it was another way in to tell
the stories of the streets
uh that I that I know well so I read I
could be wrong about this that something
happened to you when you were 15 years
old that changed your life and literally
helped you on this path to becoming a
filmmaker yeah I was wrong Clays wrong
time I was shot when I was 15.
um
going to store to get macaroni and
cheese for my mother back in Pittsburgh
it was raining and a guy got robbed
and he just stepped out with a shotgun
he just started shooting
and me and my buddy Clifford just
happened to be cutting through an
alleyway
and um
yeah luckily it was an amp Supermarket
we could run into and uh that changed my
life uh really just simply because you
know it makes you realize how fragile
life is how quickly it can go and if you
got dreams and aspirations uh you better
do it right now because tomorrow's not
promised the next second is not promise
you know I was uh I was talking back to
my grandmother she said no God doesn't
like ugly
boy was she right
and so yeah after that I you know I
started going to the movie theaters
quite a bit after that you know just to
not be in the streets yeah I'm curious
you've directed a number of things which
of you are films do you think changed
the most in the editing room in ways you
didn't expect that's a really good
question you know they all change in
ways right movies change from the script
form it's made
one movie your storyboard a movie a
designer movie you cast a movie and each
thing you do it keeps changing and
evolving
and by the time you film the movie
and get it to the editing Bay
it's changed again
every one of them and then when you put
it in front of an audience it's a
different movie because the audience
comes in from a different perspective
right so I they all change quite a bit
you know
um
The Equalizer is a movie that developed
a little bit in an editing Bay the first
one to the third one the first well this
one actually this one developed quite a
bit you know because you know there's a
pacing in the film and there's character
development and you know there's
relationships you want to build and
there's beautiful uh Italy you know on
the Mafi coast and you can kind of fall
in love with these shots in these places
and these people and get lost and and
trying to find the right Rhythm the
right pace the right tone giving the
audience enough of each character so
they feel fulfilled and you feel like
there's relationships there developed
quite a bit with this one because
there's more there's there's a lot of
things on the editing editing room floor
it's just um
it would slow things down and also it
was hurting other areas
um even the ending that you just
witnessed that ending was from another
scene
it it kind of you know it kind of comes
to me sometime in the middle of the
night I'm like
well we had a whole different ending
and I thought this is about a
celebration of the people of the place
and that soccer game was earlier
and uh I went to I called my editor
comrade buff and I said what if we put
that at the end
so he's there with the people and it was
one of those rare moments with Denzel
and Denzel's dancing and smiling and
anybody knows Denzel Stephen hey that's
not all the time you know so he was
dancing and smiling I just thought
that's a proper way to say goodbye to
Robert McCall in a positive way you know
so this one developed quite a bit in the
editing Bay I want to jump backwards uh
if you don't mind early in your career
directed a lot of music videos is there
one besides Coolio and gangster paradise
is there one that you uh like really
sticks out for you is one that you want
to you wish more people would watch you
know
you know it's hard there's there's a
there's one that sticks out to me
because of the whole situation and and
how I came about and who it was it was
Prince
the prince was a wild one man because
I love Prince
and uh he called me one day to come down
to to
um to his place and uh it was about
minus 21 degrees it's freezing you could
spit and you could it would freeze and
you know Prince works on his own time
man and so uh I'm in the bed sleeping I
think it was two or three in the morning
and Prince had a deep voice of people
who really knew him so he would call me
up and he goes uh wake up
who is this he said uh we call himself
at that time he said uh the boss or
something like I said the boss I said
who's boss
he says the boss I said whose ball he
said it's me
Prince and I was like oh what's
happening what's happening man and he
goes I'm ready
[Music]
I was like to do what
he said come down to Paisley Park you
know I'm already filming the most
beautiful girl in the world video I said
well I haven't scouted man I haven't
prepped anything you know he goes no
just come down
freezing cold I go down Paisley Park
there's like females everywhere I mean
just everywhere and I was like you've
already been casting man like what's
happening so but but the crazy thing is
I walked in is these long steps these
steps he had and I was looking for him
and uh I saw this like red outfit coming
down with these heels on and you know I
mean it was see-through Paisley and I'm
just like what the and he comes
down and he stands a few steps ahead of
me and you can see right through it
and he was like I'm ready I said you
gonna wear that
yeah so I called my DP Giorgio we went
to he had a he had a sound stage and all
that
and we just started doing it man it was
like four or five in the morning like we
just got going set him up on the stage I
said Shadow all that down here because
he wasn't changing his clothes it was
Prince but yeah that one you know just
stands out to me because of of of Prince
being so special that that night you
know yeah that one stands out for me
thank you for sharing that
uh what do you think would surprise
people to learn about making like a big
Hollywood movie uh would surprise people
about making a big Hollywood movie
um
you know I don't know there's so many
things that would surprise people about
making a Hollywood movie uh one of the
things that's that's most surprising is
how
collaboration
and working together is the only way
you're going to make a movie in
Hollywood the only way and you need so
many people to do it you know
um I tell Pas and everybody else this is
your movie too your name's on it forever
as well
you know what I mean so get it together
right if that's what you want to do
um but
I think you you the compromising is
normally a bad word
and it's not really in a Hollywood movie
because sometimes
compromising in the right way with a
positive attitude
could lead to something you never saw
coming
you know I've had many arguments with
like Tom Rothman I love Tom
you know me and Tom disagreed on a lot
of different things
uh
but somehow when you
get in the mix with them in a positive
way there's always something that
somebody's feeling and if you're smart
enough to listen you never know what
that might be it might be four scenes
before or four scenes after
there you go that's it's not this scene
that's bothering them it's the scene
here that's causing this to be a problem
and so you have to constantly be uh
fluid and open to listen at least you
know we all come into a thing that we're
going to be the next scarcity or the
next you know you know Copeland All That
until you meet them and they tell you
all all the crazy things they went
through some of the greatest scenes ever
made you know so you just have to be
open that's always surprising to people
is that you have to be willing to be
open and compromised but not in a
negative way just be open you've been
directing for over 20 years and I'm
curious when you step on set how has
your process changed from when you first
made like Replacement Killers click
equalizer is it a similar thing with you
or have you changed as a result of all
the films you've made uh I've changed
quite a bit you know I'm much more
patient
um it's like an athlete the game slows
down a bit you start seeing things
differently you start to um what I call
rubber balls and glass balls right the
rubber balls bounce back up the glass
balls break you got to know which what
um but also training day was a turning
point for me a reminder really because
when I was doing the scenes with Denzel
and Ethan
I literally would sit on an Apple box
and was never looked once I looked
through the lens I never went to the
monitor I sat literally watching these
two Master actors go at it
and it was the most fun I ever had I was
laughing my ass off and trying not to
like interfere with the dialogue and I
would forget to yell cut half the time
and and Denzel would look back at
me like you're going your cut and I was
like oh yeah cut you know because it was
like that's the reason you do it
that's the reason you do it to watch
these amazing individuals
become these people
you know you could do coming out of
music videos and commercials it was a
visual medium so everything we do is all
about style and being cool and and you
realize yeah that's nice and all that
but nobody gives a if you don't
care about the people in the film the
characters so that changed me quite a
bit it reminded me why I wanted to make
the movies and uh so yeah it's good to
change I read you are a big core sour
fan no big time yeah yeah so do you have
for someone who has not seen any of his
work obviously you should watch his
resume but what do you think what's the
one or two that you really want to
single out and tell people you need to
go watch these well you should certainly
watch uh Seven Samurai I mean you know I
never thought I would get a chance to
even I mean I made Magnificent Seven
which is based on the Seven Samurai the
Seven Samurai is the reason I make
movies and when you people like you when
we talk bring it up to me I realize
there's a through line about Justice the
samurai who who's helping other people
for a bowl of rice
they're doing it for no other reason but
because it's the right thing to do
that's what the equalizer really is it's
a samurai right which is what Samurai
means to serve and I find myself making
the same movie in some way it's all
about Justice you know
um so that's one you should certainly
watch uh ran you should definitely watch
I believe Iran was based on a king Lear
uh it's an amazing film just visually
and it's just like you're not going to
do better watching either one of those
films yeah his resume is not bad not bad
yeah not bad uh so I do want to touch on
just real fast we're almost at equalizer
I promise but uh how so you did the
Coolio video Gangster's Paradise uh and
that video actually opened doors for you
to do what you're doing so talk a little
bit about getting before you were like a
movie director getting to direct
Michelle Pfeiffer and how that video
changed your life yeah um that was
interesting um I was at the time I
propaganda films on commercials and
videos and I got a call from uh Jerry
Bruckheimer uh to do a music video for
uh Dangerous Minds and uh
with Coolio and I was like yeah that'd
be cool I'd like to do it but if
Michelle Pfeiffer is in it it'll be
better
you know and I'm thinking Jerry's going
to be like yeah okay that's not gonna
happen
and he goes okay we talked and he called
me back I think a couple days later he
goes here's her number call her and tell
her your idea
and I was like
really
yeah and so I called her and I'm nervous
and she's so cool man she was the nicest
lady I told her the idea and she said
all right let's do it
and so when I did that video the movie
became a big hit and everyone thought
the images in that film
was in the movie
and that's what Hollywood start the
combining music videos at that time with
the films and monster Cody's the kid I
was talking about his son is actually in
that video I put him in there so
um that changed my life you know the
ages started calling after that and you
know the whole Hollywood thing you know
for a long time people thought I was
this French director you know Antoine
Fuqua man you know I'd have people come
in the room and be look at me and go hey
can you go get me some coffee
and I was like no I am Antoine Fuqua
he's like oh you know yeah so yeah you
know Hollywood started calling and you
know John Woo called and it went from
there yeah I can't imagine that phone
call I couldn't either yeah I couldn't
either uh so of the films you've made
which shot or sequence gave you the most
nightmares toughest to pull off I think
everything in emancipation
everything in there was so hard to make
um that film was was shot
uh it was a hundred and God knows what
degrees every day in New Orleans we
filmed it in the swamps
you can't put anything on the ground
everything in there wants to kill you
uh alligators everywhere
uh the hurricane shutters down covet
shut us down our tornado shut us down
uh the subject matter was heartbreaking
every day of course
uh
the battle scene was probably the most
complicated
thing I've ever done in emancipation you
know yeah the first time you directed
Denzel uh he wins an Oscar does that
mean like basically what does that
actually mean because I'm joking around
about this but does that mean you can
pretty much just text him anytime and be
like so I'm making this movie so you're
coming right
uh
yeah yes and no so
I said this is all I need to uh I need
to have a coffee with you man I want to
talk to you about this movie and he goes
all right so we get together and I said
all right I had a whole pitch it's like
so the sun is coming up it's just this
man on this black horse can we go what
what
I said a man on his horse and his cell
was like I'm gonna get on the horse
I said no no let me finish
Magnificent Seven and he just sat back
and listens to me let me get my pitch
and like halfway through my pitch I'm
thinking gazelle's gonna give a walk
away any moment he's gonna be like no
I'm not getting on the damn horse
playing the cowboy you know but he
listened he listened for a while that
took a while to get to get him to say
yes to a magnificent seven but he still
did
but he still didn't yeah he still did
jumping into equalizer uh so you've now
made three films and the thing about
Hollywood is that they always talk about
oh like we'll make a sequel blah blah
blah never happens but what is it
about this character in this these films
and that has caught that resonates with
so many people that is the franchise of
you and Denzel well I mean Denzel
himself is a draw obviously
uh with Sony and the producers uh Todd
black and Jason Blumenthal at one point
we did a test uh just asking people
random tests I think they did a uh a
whole survey what was most important to
most people
and uh money fame or Justice what do you
think won
Justice
it's about Justice
people want Justice even if it's in the
Hollywood fun way they want Justice and
they want to see Denzel Washington
dishing it out you know but the bad guys
have to be real bad guys you know it's
got to feel like there's a connection
because he's a working man's hero he's
an everyday hero he's not flying around
on kites and doing flips and all that
you know he's like a guy he could
be anybody in his room you know uh I
think people were connecting to that
that uh
accessibility so I've read that this is
the last installment of this franchise
I'm going to just use one word why
well I mean I think we've given
we've explored Robert McCall enough you
know everything has to come to an end uh
I think
it's a nice send-off that he's found a
place because the first one is about
finding purpose he was trying to find a
purpose when he found it the second one
is about dealing with the past his wife
Diane Susan getting murdered his friends
betraying them the popes
and he had to deal with his past
and this one is about finding a place in
life
you know that you feel it could be home
in some peace where do you go from that
pretty cool I'm curious how you ended up
in Italy in term because the first two
how are you gonna ask somebody how you
how you end up in Italy no no no what no
there's obviously the whole world so how
did you pick Italy besides the amazing
food and wine well
Vino no uh Denzel loves Italy he's been
going to Italy with his children since
they weren't babies uh positana and the
Mediterranean and then he introduced me
to him years ago so I started going
there a lot and spending time there uh
and uh and uh
on their mafikos and we talked about
different places but I wanted it to be a
place that he felt at home that he felt
comfortable with
um
also I forget what film I was promoting
me and Denzel were together in Rome
and we walked out of this restaurant
and I'm
we couldn't get down the street it was
so many people that found out he was
there just packed just like crazy like
the Beatles And I was like let me get
the out of here man because he got
bodyguards you know I'm by myself I'm
with Denzel and his people you know but
it I realized what an international star
he was in Italy was a place that felt
warm to him and I watched how people
respond to him in Italy when we sit and
like uh have dinner together and Mama
comes out
you know and she's like feeding us like
we would she wouldn't stop feeding us
you know and the wine kept flowing and
they just love him and I said let's set
it somewhere that he feels comfortable
as well so that's how Italy came out
plus it's also an amazing place I mean
to film in Rome and chinichita where
Fellini filmed to film in Naples which
is an amazing City if anybody's been in
Naples it's gritty it reminds me of New
York in the 70s and then felony and Mafi
Coast uh to play that place is called a
we call it Altamonte and wake up
every day looking at the Mediterranean
it's like
where else are you going to film it you
know Budapest
you know what I'm saying this film is
going to be like White Lotus in terms of
getting people to Italy yeah you know
maybe maybe it's a beautiful place I
suggest you go if you haven't been so
one of the things uh this movie is a
little violent uh there's there's a
little Blood and Guts a little bit yeah
and so I'm curious how where do you find
the line of what you're willing to show
um and do you ever get Studio pushback
or the MPAA pushback or how do you find
it I've got no pushback from the studio
or or the mpa
um
the violence for me as a director is
it's it's all it's like dialogue
the violence is dialogue for me and you
have someone like Denzel Washington it
can't just be violence it has to be a
reason is happening and you have to
still see them performing that's the
thing I focus on a lot the first one
when he puts the corkscrew in a guy is
because these guys are you know human
trafficking little girls
I want you to see the light go out in
this motherfucker's eyes
you know that's how evil this person is
and so the audience responds to that and
anybody that watches the movie feels the
same so you can get away with that
because of the bad guys were so bad
right
um that's one of the things that
helps
get past the core because uh
he becomes the monster
right it's like this movie in particular
equalizer 3 is about
they're terrorizing people right they're
terrorists that's what they are all
right and so what happens when you flip
that what happens when you come home and
all your people are dead and your boy is
hanging with a corkscrew in his mouth
right just the way you threw the old man
out the window right so now you're the
victim now you're being terrorized so
when you do that for the story and also
mentally where is Robert McCall that's
the violence is all about where he is
mentally so in the beginning he's darker
he's mean he shoots the guy in the ass
like he tortures him right because he's
dealing with his own internal struggle
with violence that's one of the things
me and Denzel talked a lot about was
there's guys that get off on violence
and it just happens right there's
special forces people who live a certain
life and it becomes a thing right it's
like sex right Robert McCall was on the
edge
he he's alone now he has no one else so
is he killing for himself now or is he
really doing it for the people
and so of course God steps in and we all
saw the movie now
and says you need to slow down and
rethink what you're doing and what
you're doing it for right so that
violence was about where he was mentally
that's why he puts the gun to his head
because he doesn't even like himself
anymore you know so the violence is all
about character
especially with someone like Denzel
Washington
you know he's like I said he's not doing
the ballet
he's performing
yeah so uh I just obviously we're in
IMAX headquarters and we're watching
everyone saw it in IMAX it's my favorite
format I love IMAX it's amazing yeah
talk I mean it's it's a little uh talk a
little bit about uh why you should see
films in IMAX especially equalizer I
mean the scope you're never going to see
it like this ever again you know the
scope of this is just incredible the
sound uh it's what you make movies for
you know to put it on a screen like this
to have this sort of a shared experience
in IMAX you'll never see it again like
this you know
um it's really important to experience
it this way this is what Cinema is this
is what it's all about when I was a
little boy and I first saw Close
Encounters or those films you know with
my dad you know they were like Larger
than Life
you know that's what movies are about so
IMAX is the best way to watch it yeah uh
I there's nothing like I mean it's so
it's uh everyone says it but there is
really nothing like seeing a movie in a
movie theater it's just nothing like it
it's a shared experience that's what we
make it for like I said movies are
remade you know you make a movie I sit
there by myself in the screening rooms
and stuff you know with my popcorn and
coke and yeah it's great you know and
then I get in the room with like three
or four other people it changes
get in a room with more people they
laugh at certain places I'm like was
that supposed to be funny I was that
supposed to be a serious scene you know
but but you start to experience it in a
whole different way and that's the magic
of it that actually leads me to my next
question which is uh what have you
learned in this film in particular what
did you learn from any friends and
family screenings or test screenings
that impacted the finished film you know
what people care about sometimes or the
smallest things I'll give you an example
from the first one uh the girl gets
robbed as a cash register
and you know there's a whole scene where
McCall goes and handles the guy that
robbed the place with the hammer
and I remember saying I'm just going to
see him pick up the hammer we already
know what McCall does and at the end of
the movie The Ring is in the drawer
right the drawer opens and her ring is
there I hated that scene the
studio was like oh no it's beautiful and
I was like ah it's so corny
put that in the movie suck the audience
loved it
they love they love the sentiment of it
they loved it you know and it was like
sometimes you know we get so caught up
on how cool we are and what we
think we know until you get in the room
with a bunch of people you don't know
you know that you don't know anything
because you make it for the audience and
all of a sudden they love when we did
the cards that was one of their favorite
moments
so that's a big lesson talk a little bit
about I'm curious what it's like in the
editing room and how much does Denzel
visit you in the editing room and how
much it never ever he's never visited me
to editing room Denzel doesn't come look
at my monitor that's part of our
relationship we on Training Day
we did a scene in the cafe when he tells
you can talk to pay the bill
I got what I wanted and you know Denzel
Washington I was like dude you want to
come over look at the monitor he said
man you flying this he said you
flying This Plane man call me when you
need me and God have been walked away
and I'm like oh I better not
this up
like that's but that sort of trust
you know that and it freed me right and
we had an agreement that we never tie
each other's hands right and that was
our agreement and that's our trust so he
never ever is coming to edit anybody he
doesn't come into my monitors he doesn't
come look at what I'm doing he gives you
his performance
the choices we discuss those things and
he goes off and
chills until we need them and that's our
relationship I'm curious uh how many
takes do you typically like to do when
you're filming and how many takes does
Denzel like to do we only do what we
really need I mean um
three takes is a lot for me and Denzel
that's like three to four takes
really because there's always some
technical thing here and there you know
um
we both believe in there's and every
actor is different right but you only
get that moment once that's what makes
great actors great actors
you get that moment once right and
no matter what they're doing
is never going to be the same right and
if you the more takes you do down the
line you start to burn out the the uh
used to burn out the the rawness of it
the truth right the truth normally comes
early you know it comes right away right
if you're a great actor you did your
work before and that's what Denzel does
so
maybe three takes if it's a fourth tag
we're going off book a little bit and
we're playing because we're having some
fun and we want to around a little
bit or he's got something he wants to do
or I'll go to him and say something
normally with Denzel and I'm blessed
really because we have this relationship
is I swear I'll be sitting here in
Denzel I'll go cut and I'll go indeed
you know what uh he could already know I
know I'm like you sure you know and then
he would do it
and I'm like that's weird or he
would he would uh
I would go to him and say I want you to
adjust something and he would kind of go
like
what what did I do
what do you mean and I was like you know
when you did the thing he goes I don't
even remember man all right let me hold
on a second because he's in the moment
that moment's real right I remember one
time
he was doing some inequalizer too with
the kid in the house and he was about to
do something and I'm watching him I'm
watching him and he's used to me
watching them for a while but then I for
whatever reason I said okay cut and he
went uh uh and I hate to see him that
way because I it hit me I was like ah
he was about to do something
that was gone forever I don't even I
didn't even want to know what it was he
was going to do it was something he was
about to do and I that up right
because
you only get that moment once and so
three takes
maybe four if we're playing a little bit
you used Robert Richardson as your DP on
this you worked with him on emancipation
uh what is he like as a collaborator and
what made you want to work with him
again on equalizer three Bob Richardson
is just a genius
um you know three Academy Awards he
worked with the greatest directors that
I'm you know my heroes as well Oliver
Stone Mark Scorsese he shoots Quentin's
movies and things like that he's like a
little little wizard man with that gray
hair you know he's just magic and he he
doesn't sleep he's a lot like me he's up
all night sending me images and
long texted sometimes I don't know what
the he's talking about but he's
like brilliant you know and he's just
he's one of these he's a brother man and
like I love him you know and we're so
similar on emancipation you know there's
alligators are not swung
and you know when I first asked Bob to
do the movie he goes no I hate
snakes I'm not doing it and I talked him
into doing it
but he was in the swan with me man Knee
Deep going out to these places like he
was like a warrior man and Bob is on the
set before everybody I kept trying to
beat him to the center like I'm gonna
beat him today I'm gonna beat him and he
would be up all night I'm like when the
do you sleep and he would be on the
set before me every time I've never beat
Bob Richardson to the set but he's just
one of these people that loves
Cinema
he like loves it he's an artist
and and he's a filmmaker we discuss
script character we'd spend a lot of
time together
genius so Roger deacons famously shoots
with one camera and Ridley Scott will do
six or eight cameras and shoot you know
it completely radically different ways
of working and I'm curious which way do
you like to work and has it changed
through your career in the beginning I
liked a lot of cameras coming out of
commercials and videos you know you want
to capture everything you know he's
shooting every angle just like
you know
uh as as you as I mature One camera is
really the focus
but every once in a while I'll have
maybe two depends on the scene
right but it needs to be very specific
to what I want now it's not a hosing
down thing uh one camera is what it's
really all about for me now you know
because it's it's all about
uh
the relationship between me and that
frame has to be complete I can't think
about the other cameras anymore right
because
when you're younger you are not
confident enough I I wasn't when I was
younger you know uh I didn't want to
miss anything but now
yeah I'm pretty precise how much do you
let go and are you willing to let your
second unit director take on stuff and
how much you like I'm shooting that
I'm always like I'm shooting that
but
uh I I've met uh Rob Legato uh
who shot forces as well through Bob and
Rob I have complete trust in when we
discuss everything I storyboard
everything lay it out
and then you know I always give an
artists like that room you know we get
what we want but then he'll see
something and like go get it you
know in emancipation there's some great
shots in there with the horses chasing
the Rob shot you know I told them what I
wanted and he would go over there and
shoot it but they'd bring it to me right
away immediately and I see it right away
um but yeah if you got a great artist
you got to let them you know gotta let
them fly a little bit so I'm curious in
the editing room by the way he's got
three Academy Awards too I believe so
you know I don't have one
I think Rob Rob could shoot a couple
things for me uh uh I'm curious how long
the film is like an hour and 45 minutes
or so how long was the cut that you had
that was there a longer cut of the film
that you were super happy with
um how you know what I mean did you yes
this film was never more than it was
about I'd say 215. and I wasn't happy
with it that's what I mean I could I
couldn't find a rhythm of it at first
for whatever reason you know and I think
a lot of it had to do is because of
coming out of emancipation you know the
whole thing I'm not gonna get into that
but the whole Academy thing uh
it took a toll on me a little bit and I
didn't realize
you know and uh
I had to catch up to myself a little bit
so my rhythm was off
you know and so when I got into the
editing Bay
my rhythm felt off and it took me a
while and I had to watch it and watch it
and and let it come to me more and more
and more
um
to where it felt
right the heartbeat felt right
and then as I chiseled and chiseled and
chiseled and chiseled away
I was still like I was getting better
and I chiseled some more and I was like
I'm still not missing it and I cut this
out and I was like I didn't miss that at
all and I kept going until I felt like
okay if I go any further I'm gonna hurt
it
you know and then I called Conrad like
literally in the mix
the day before we finished and I was
telling them let's put this thing back
let's football back it's like what the
you talking about like the movie's
done I was like gotta put it back gotta
find a way to do it because then I
started putting a couple things back in
right because my rhythm was just off and
things were coming a little um
uh a little late to me I'm curious what
you are like directing on set and uh not
not with Denzel because obviously you
have a short hand but with other people
how do you like to direct and
um what do you do when you're not
getting what you want yeah
when I was younger I would yell which is
stupid
I was I was mean I think
because I just didn't you know some of
it comes out of fear of failure you know
you react like a child
and that doesn't get you what you want
um now I you know like I said I'm much
more patient
uh
I
I plan I think I plan differently now
um
if I'm not getting what I want I'll
always get what I want
I'm going to get what I want
but sometimes like I said the compromise
is
okay I can't get exactly what I want
but I'm gonna create something out of
this moment
right
weather
not enough money or anything can happen
all kind of weird right
uh
now my strategy is okay what's the gift
right if I have done everything I can do
to get everything I can get out of this
but I can't get what I want
what's the gift
you know what I'm saying there's a gift
in there somewhere right that's how I
see it because I if I've exhausted
everything
what's the gift and sometimes that's
like you know what this is actually
better
sometimes
you know sometimes sometimes there's
some days where I I can't I don't even
watch my own films back because I
remember those moments where I didn't
get a gift and I'm like
I wish I could have done that a little
better you know
so yeah but that's that's my my
directing is much more patient and um
yeah uh we're nearing the end of our q a
but I do want to ask you uh you are
possibly making a Michael Jackson film
yeah yeah I'm very excited about that
yeah
absolutely
I can't get into it right now obviously
but man I'm telling you I'm very excited
about that movie I'm very excited about
telling Michael's story it's gonna be
like I'm getting the wrap up so it's
like I'll leave that on uh see what he
does slide me up man you owe me another
t-shirt for that one that hard man
she gets eight years to you know hit you
um but uh one last thing so you were
involved in the terminal list yeah super
successful on Prime video what do you
think it is about that series that like
and also Chris Pratt super popular in
Prime video what do you think it is
about that series that material that
resonated and caused it to be such a
huge hit ah man it's fun you know
um Chris is a badass in it for real you
know you play on a Navy SEAL
um again it's Justice I mean it again
it's Justice his family gets murdered
and
the people that murdered his family
we're going to meet the Dark Wolf
and that's what it is it's Justice
people want to see Justice that's what
it's all about I know they're making I
think a prequel series
yes we are doing it yeah I was going to
say how is that moving along well the
strike stopped everything obviously but
we're moving along we were at a good
click you know we're excited about it
you know
um Chris and in the team uh we're ready
to go as soon as they
you know solve the issues
we're off and running on that note I'm
just going to tell everyone if you
enjoyed the equalizer 3 there's this
thing called social media may I suggest
using it
um please yeah and on that if you like
it if you're positive if not just keep
it to yourself it's all good
and on that note ladies and gentlemen
Antoine Fuqua thanks guys
thank you guys